Okay.
So now we have a number of different perspectives we can take on understanding
what holds molecules together.
That is on bonding.
We can look at the real molecule,
for example,
with X-ray or,
uh,
we can,
we can do a computer calculation and if we do a careful enough computer
calculation,
we can get something that we believe is pretty close to reality.
Like the total electron density I showed you.
Right?
Uh,
and the,
the goal of the computer is to approximate the Schrodinger equation.
You can't do it.
Absolutely.
But you can,
you can,
depending on how much computer power you want to throw at it,
you can do it close enough for most purposes.
Okay.
But you're neither the molecule while you are a molecule.
But,
uh,
you're neither the kind of molecule we're studying.
Nor are you're a computer.
Are you a computer?
You're a chemist.
And your goal is to understand things.
Let the computer do the heavy lifting mathematically and you understand it.
Okay.
So let's see if we can understand some of the things that we didn't understand
when we were looking at the molecule really with ex-ray diffraction,
right when we were looking at,
we looked at this molecule and said that the bonding from the Lewis point of
view was pathological.
And you remember how we saw that?
We looked at a cross section through those three atoms and it looked like that
in the electron difference density.
And you remember what's funny about it?
What's pathological data?
Some of the bonds are bent and what else?
And one bond is missing.
So that bond isn't there.
And the electron density,
the difference density,
and those are bent there.
They don't lie on the line between the nuclei.
Now can we understand that from the point of view of molecular orbitals of
Schrodinger's equation,
why it should look like that in this particular case?
Uh,
so would a computer's molecular orbitals provide understanding?
So I was just showing you as the class assembled how you get these molecular
orbitals and I was showing you some of them.
And one,
there's the framework of the molecule super imposed on this map.
And those,
that triangle on top there on the right is what we're looking at.
And so we could look at the 32nd of the 33 occupied orbitals the next to the
highest occupied orbital.
And it looks like that.
That's the one we were just looking at before we went onto the PowerPoint.
And you see there is electron density in those,
uh,
the,
the wave function has big value in the region where those bonds are bent,
but they're 33 of these occupied orbitals and they put electron density every
which way.
And it's very difficult to understand why this is the way it is,
why it's been even if you grant,
which is not easy to grant,
that this is the proper orbital to look and that indeed the electron density of
that red and blue,
big red and blue lobes are not on the line between,
between we don't know why they are right.
And there's so much other electron density,
the motto molecule with all complicated nodes that it's very difficult to know
where to look.
Right?
So,
uh,
the answer is no.
It doesn't provide understanding that it gives far too complicated than answer.
It doesn't tell you why.
Even if you believe that it gives you the right numbers.
Okay.
But analysis in terms of pairwise,
that is don't go over the whole molecule.
Just look at two Adams adjacent to one another,
making a bond.
So just a very local view.
Pairwise bonding overlap of hybrid.
Atomic orbitals explains these two pathologies.
So let's look first.
I will assert that the best overlap you can get between a hybrid orbitals on
these carbons.
If the,
if the nuclei are arranged in an equal lateral triangle.
So 60 degree angles,
the best hybrids,
you can get points at the angles shown by the red arrows here.
That's they do it in order to get the best overlap.
Now this seems funny because the angle between the red arrows on the right
carbon is greater than 90 degrees.
Why do I say it's funny that it's greater that you're not going to be able to
make it 60 degrees?
Because two orbitals that made a 60 degree angle would not be independent
orbitals.
They would be very,
obviously,
if they were right on top of one another,
they'd be the same orbital,
but you can't say they're not the same word bill if they're just a little bit of
way,
because still they're mostly the same orbital.
It's only once they get the 90 degrees that they could be different.
What would the orbitals B that would be independent of one another at 90 degrees
p orbitals.
Right,
so 90 degrees is this smallest angle you could get.
Why don't you use 90 degrees?
Why do you use greater than 90 degrees?
Okay,
that's the question.
Why not use P orbitals and make the smallest angle you can?
Does anybody see by that is
here.
There there's a PR battle that points at 90 degrees.
You see that it's access.
The yellow axis is a little bit inside the red Arrow and the blue access,
which would be another p orbital perpendicular to that one is a little inside
the other red era.
They make an angle of 90 degrees.
Got It.
Now,
why don't the Adams used p orbitals to make the smallest possible angle?
Can anybody see why that won't give the best overlap?
How could you change the orbital so as to get better overlap?
[inaudible]
uh,
number that depends on the distance and they're very close to one another and it
turns out it might be that at this angle,
if you use the s on one of the,
on one of the carbons and the P on another,
it might be that you would get better overlap.
It's,
I don't know that it's true,
but it's,
it's not implausible.
But what would be wrong about using this p orbital from that carbon and on the
top one of the triangle using an s,
which might give better overlap.
Can you see what's bad about that?
If you use all the assets of that top carbon there,
you can't use any of it to make any of the other bonds from that carbon.
Right?
All you have left over on that one is,
is which give crummy overlap.
So even though you might be able to make this single overlap better,
you couldn't make all the bonds strong from that top carbon so you wouldn't get
the best overall overlap.
So that's a good suggestion.
But there's another way to do it,
which is to use a hybrid orbital.
Now here we've put in a little bit,
uh,
a little bit less than 20% of s to give the ratio s p 4.1 right?
But notice that it really distorted.
It made it much larger in the region where we're interested in an overlapping,
right?
In the process,
the axis moved out right to where the red Arrow it close to where the Red Arrow
is.
Right?
But even though the bonds didn't point,
let's see like this,
even though the bonds didn't point at one another,
right?
By extending,
they overlap more.
Got The idea.
So the hybridization by shifting it to one side gives better overlap,
even though the angle might not be quite as good.
Okay.
So that's,
so you have bent bonds paradoxically enough in order to get the best overlap.
Isn't that funny?
You'd think the best overlap would be when they'd point at one another.
But you get better when they make an angle because they stretch out.
Okay,
so that explains the bent bonds.
Now how about the missing bond?
Well again,
we can see that in hybridization because what's left over after you make those
sp four point ones,
three of them
pointing up from the,
from the bottom carbon after you make three sp four point ones.
What you have left over is an sp 1.4 and it points down not up.
If it pointed up,
if the blue big blue lobe we're up in the red down,
then it would part of those other three orbitals.
The only way you could make it point up is to make the other's point down.
Right.
And then they would have crummy overlap.
So there's very poor overlap between the tiny lobes of these two.
So there's not enough overlap to get a bond.
You don't don't stabilize the electrons because there's,
you don't have overlap.
Right.
And Re hybridizing this one to strengthen this particular bond by making it
point up would drastically weaken all the others.
Making them point down.
Right?
So the best overall overlap for all the payers that are involved in these bonds
is to have one bond not there or to have very,
very poor overlaps so that the other three are very good.
Sam,
I ever done the other two.
If you get sp fourth wave one,
and if I understood that that shifts the electrons towards the other end.
Okay,
but how does that shifting distorted?
Remember the angle between hybrids depends on m and N.
Dot.
SPM and Spn,
we did that last time.
If it's pure P,
it's 90 degrees.
If it's sp three sp three it's a,
it's a a hundred it's 109 and a half.
If it's sp two sp two it's 120 and so on.
If it's sp 4.1 it makes that certain angle that shown they're bigger than 90
degrees.
Okay.
And that the only reason for that is so that these hybrids will be different
from one another.
They won't be the same.
Right.
They won't overlap each other on the same Adam because to the extent they do,
they're the same.
And so they can't at all.
They have to be orthogonal if they're on the same Adam.
Okay.
Now three views of Bh.
Three first nature,
that total electron density.
I'm going over the same thing again and again here with different examples.
First look at total electron density nature.
Then we'll look at molecular orbitals.
That's what a computer does.
And then we'll look at bonds from hybrid atomic orbitals and that's what we do
as chemists.
Okay.
First we'll look at the electron cloud of Bh three calculated here on using that
same program I just showed you.
So we can look at the success of uh,
layers of the onion,
right?
The high electron density,
lower,
the various contours.
So this lowest one is mostly one s of Boron,
but a little bit of the one s as of hydrogen to,
and one of them doesn't even show up because it's so small.
All the hydrogens should be the same.
But that the graphing,
uh,
capability of the computer for something that's,
that has as few as this,
the way it draws surfaces doesn't draw them smooth,
right?
It connects points.
So it doesn't even show one of those.
Nobody would ever make such a plot.
Okay.
Down at that,
that's 0.3 electrons per cubic Hong strum.
So suppose we go to 0.15 electrons per cubic songs strum half that density.
Now we're beginning to get smoother surfaces and it's on the Boron is one s of
the Boron and a little bit of the hydrogens as well,
right?
And now we're going to lower electron density 0.05 and now there's an
interesting feature you can see here.
You see that dimple?
Why is that?
Why is there not as much electron density at this level around the Boron?
We're out in the valence shell now,
not one s anymore,
right?
Cause the one s is really down close high density.
It's because the hydrogen atoms are pulling the electron density away from the
Valence Adams of Boron.
Often you talk about this in terms of electronegativity,
but why is something electronegative?
It's because of what the effective nuclear charge is.
The effective nuclear charge of hydrogen for the valence level is one,
right?
But for Boron it should be higher.
Boron is,
is the fifth element,
but it's got the,
uh,
the,
the one s electrons shielding the nucleus,
so it's not as,
as high in effective nuclear charges.
Hydrogen does.
So when you put the orbitals together,
hydrogen is lower than Boron,
and the electrons in those bonds are mostly on the hydrogen.
So you'll see that dimple in the middle because there's not much valence
electron density on the Boron.
Now we go to 0.02 electrons per cubic construct and finally to point double o
two electrons per cubic drum,
which is defined as for purposes of drawing what the Vander walls surfaces.
That is how close molecules tend to get to one another at normal pressure in a
liquid or in a crystal.
Right?
And that's,
it's just found empirically just by testing and measuring things that,
that if you draw a surface at 0.02 electrons per cubic construct you have about
how close things would come to one another when you bumped these surfaces into
one another.
Okay.
So that's the Vanderwall surface.
That's a definition,
right?
And we did,
we showed once before electrostatic potential where you show that same surface
but color it to show how the electrons are distributed and the protons in the
molecule.
So as so where would a positive charge on the surface be happy where it's
negative,
that's a red.
And where would it be unhappy?
The positive charge because the molecule is positive there.
That's the blue.
So you can see what it is.
It's red where the hydrogens are because they're pulling the electrons and it's
blue where the Boron is cause it's giving up electrons.
Okay,
so there's uh,
there's what the uh,
what the,
the real molecule looks like.
Of course,
I didn't do it by an experimental measurement for BH three because you can't
crystallize BH three.
I did it by computer calculation,
but I believe that that what it gives us,
what you would see in an experiment if you could do the experiment.
Okay,
so that's the total electron density.
Now let's look at how the computer breaks that up into molecular orbitals and a
calculation like this,
so it looks at,
it makes symmetrical molecular orbitals like Claude,
the things with nodes,
we've seen lots of those.
So here's this framework,
Bh h three and we're going to look at the molecular orbitals,
the computer calculates,
and we're going to make those electron,
those molecular orbitals by adding up atomic orbitals linear combination of
atomic orbitals and which atomic orbitals.
Where will we use in the best would be if we used every atomic orbital,
then we could get perfect flexibility,
but the calculation would take too long.
So we use just a minimal number of atomic orbitals,
namely the the one s orbital on Boron and also the valence orbitals two s two
Px,
two p y to be z,
and also the one s or orbitals of hydrogen.
So there are one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
There are eight atomic orbitals we're going to use to make up our molecular
orbitals.
How many independent molecular orbitals can we make?
If we start with eight atomic orbitals,
we could make a molecular orbitals the same number you started with.
If you tried to make more,
they wouldn't be independent of one another,
but you can make from eight you make eight.
Okay?
So these are going to be the energy's.
It'll turn out of the eight molecular orbitals that we're going to get,
that the computer is going to get started from that.
If you added more atomic orbitals v allowed to use three s three p three d and
so on,
then you'd get more molecular orbitals,
but they'd be higher in energy and less relevant.
Okay?
In fact,
how many of these are relevant?
How do we know how many we care about
the energy of
Russel?
How many electrons?
We can put two electrons into each.
Once we've got it filled up,
we don't really care what the other energies there could be,
at least not for this purpose.
Okay,
well,
it turns out that Boron has five electrons.
Hydrogen has three,
eight altogether.
So there'll be eight electrons for pairs,
and that means for occupied orbitals.
We don't care so much about the others,
right?
So those are the occupied molecular orbitals Omo.
Okay.
And then there'll be,
uh,
also from this set of atomic orbitals,
there'll be four unoccupied molecular orbitals you mos.
Okay.
Now those two are called,
nobody talks about Omo and Omo,
but they talk about homo.
That's very important.
And we'll be talking about that.
That's the highest occupied molecular orbital.
And also they're very interested in the lowest unoccupied molecular orbital.
And you'll see why very shortly.
So the Lumo and the homo are very important.
In this particular case,
it turns out they're two homos that have the same energy,
not surprisingly,
because it's such a symmetrical molecule.
Okay.
Now,
what do you think the very lowest orbital looks like,
Caitlin?
You're our expert
one.
It's the one s orbital of,
of a boron.
So there it is no surprise there.
Not to diminish your contribution,
but it's not surprising.
Okay?
So there's one s that's the boron core.
Now what's gonna come next,
do you think?
After we've got the one s molecular orbital,
what will be next to us?
But it's a molecular orbital be made up of everything.
So here it is,
right?
And it's,
it's all the hydrogens and also the Boron to Sr contributed to that.
Again,
there's a dimple in the middle,
more of the hydrogens than of the Boron.
Why?
Because the hydrogen one s is lower than the Boron two s that the boron one s
was lower.
That's was the first one,
right?
Okay.
And then so there's that radial node,
right?
The spherical sorta node down there,
middle showing,
it's a two S,
right?
And then there's two px,
molecular orbital and a two p.
Why molecular orbital?
And that's four.
And that's all eight electrons.
So that's what we care about.
They're the occupied molecular orbitals of Bh three.
Now how about the vacant orbitals?
The lowest on occupied orbital is that the last two p,
the two PC that's pointed in and out of the plane of the molecule.
And then we're going to have three s,
which you see has that node in the middle too.
So to Sperry sort of nodes
and then a d squared,
d x squared minus y squared.
And finally DXY right?
So that's the molecular orbitals that the computer generates for this thing
using what's called a minimal basis set.
That is the lowest number of orbitals you can use,
uh,
to get through that is through the valence level.
You don't put the higher ones in.
Okay.
Now that's how the computer does it,
right?
And you can get good numbers out of the computer,
like the energy of the molecule or the shape of the molecule where the nuclei
would like to be to minimize the energy.
That's fine.
But for understanding it's not so good.
What we want to do as chemist understand that is to partition the electron
density,
not into these molecular orbitals but into atom pair bonds.
Right?
And anti bonds as you'll see.
And Lone pairs,
the same stuff Louis talked about.
Okay,
that is,
we usually do this,
but sometimes it doesn't work and when doesn't it work?
When it doesn't work,
we must use more sophisticated orbitals where we say there is a certain
phenomenon going on.
You know what that phenomenon is when we can't use localized bonds.
That's what residents is.
When this approach doesn't work.
Hey,
remember that's where Lewis theory had to get sort of complicated baroque.
Okay,
so there's that too.
Pz orbital,
a vacant orbital,
right?
Here's the boron core,
but now we're doing it.
We're happy to use a vacant orbital.
That's part of Lewis's idea.
So to Peezy,
we'll share with the computer.
Both of us see that as a lowest vacant orbital.
The Boron core,
we understand quite well.
Okay,
but how are we going to treat those other three pairs of electrons in the
picture?
Louis would draw.
Where would Lewis put those three pairs of dots?
Angela can't hear.
Those would be the bonds between Bnh.
Okay,
so what will those look like in our crummy picture?
Right?
We're not as good,
at least I'm not as good as the computer at drawing these things,
but what I'd say,
it's going to be an orbital that's big on hydrogen,
smaller on Boron,
some hybrid sp squared.
Hybrid of Boron is going to overlap with h on height with the,
with the one s orbital of hydrogen.
It's going to be bigger on hydrogen and on Boron.
Why?
Why should the lowest?
The bonding over,
it'll be bigger on hydrogen than oxymoron.
Lucas,
uh,
one is,
yeah,
that's another way that's,
it's that that orbital,
the hydrogen Orville is lower than in lower in energy than the bore on it's
mixing with,
right?
So it's uneven mixing,
Poor energy match.
So the one that went down looks mostly like the hydrogen,
the one that went up looks mostly like the Boron.
So we see one,
in fact,
we see three of these one point in toward each hydrogen,
right?
And they all have this from our point of view,
they all have the same energy where they're all BH bonds shown as their energy
and red there.
Okay.
But notice you get the same total energy as the computer with the computer
divides the pie completely differently.
Right?
But you get the same answer,
right?
And the same geometry that the computer from the point of view of what direction
to the hybrids point and so on.
So we're getting the same structure,
we're getting the same energy.
You get the same total electron density too.
If you add all the electrons together,
three bonds add together to give the team the same way.
Remember three P orbitals added up to give a sphere,
right?
Are Three,
uh,
bonds add up to give the same energy as the computer.
So who needs a computer,
right?
Our bonds work just as well if we view them right.
Okay.
And then there would be the antibody,
the one that's what's left over that's big on age,
big on Boron,
small on h and a node between hydrogen and Boron.
It's anti-bonding the one that went up and energy when the Adams came together.
And again,
there'd be three of these sigma stars big on h big on Boron,
small on age.
They would all have the same energy.
But again,
they're,
they're average energy is the same as the average energy of unoccupied molecular
orbitals that,
that the computer gets.
So we're not doing so bad following Louis in this respect,
looking at the,
at the electron density in terms of bonds rather than in terms of molecular
orbitals.
Okay.
So for many purposes,
localized bond orbitals are not bad.
And there are certainly a heck of a lot easier to think about.
Uh,
but beware of resonance,
right?
It's cause sometimes this isn't gonna work,
so we'll have to understand how that works.
So the localized bond,
orbital picture,
pairwise molecular orbitals that is to Adam's coming together to overlap.
And also there'll be isolated at atomic orbitals like unshared payers or
isolated vacant orbitals like the Pz orbital,
a boron that we just saw that will be,
this picture will be our intermediate between hydrogen,
like atomic orbitals,
which we really understand.
You just look up in the table and you got them right.
And computer molecular orbitals,
which are too complicated really to understand in any kind of detail.
It's handy to,
sometimes for some purposes it's very handy to be able to calculate them and
look at them.
Right?
But you don't do it very often in your head.
So when West me think more deeply when the mixing,
when you have these localized orbitals but they mix to cause reactivity,
that is a molecular orbital from this molecule mixes with a molecular orbital
from this molecule and one goes down in one goes up.
That's what our reaction is.
Or when you have to pairwise orbitals in the same molecule,
right?
That we thought of as bonds are vacant orbitals or something like that.
And those interact with one another within the same molecule.
We were too simplistic and thinking of them as independent,
they interact with one another.
That's what resonance,
that's when resonance occurs is when you have important interactions within a
molecule between orbitals are what between what you thought or orbitals.
But we're thinking to simply,
so where are we?
We've gone through Adam's,
we've gone through molecules and looked at how we can understand the electron
density and molecules and now we're to the final payoff,
which is reactivity.
How can we understand reactivity in terms of SOMOS singly occupied,
molecular orbitals,
hi,
homos and low lumos.
And then how can we recognize functional groups?
So even though if he never saw them before,
we know what they're going to be react,
how reactive they are going to be and what with,
that's the payoff.
Okay.
So now we know that if you have two molecules and you're interested in,
they're reacting,
uh,
there'll be molecular orbitals of the two that come together,
interact.
And the,
if the molecule gets the,
if the energy goes down because of that,
that'll be a favorable reaction.
If the energy goes up,
they'll bounce off one another.
Okay,
so,
but they're there.
How many molecular orbitals are there on a molecule?
Suppose method,
how many molecular orbitals does it have to?
It has an infinite number,
right?
The 13 z orbital and so on.
Okay.
So it's going to be,
we have to pick out which orbitals are going to be important in interacting with
one another or else we're just going to be at a loss because there'll be so
many,
I mean,
so,
so you have these orbitals on molecule B say,
and those are occupied and the ones above are vacant,
unoccupied.
And on molecule a,
you have a bunch of occupied and a bunch of unoccupied molecular orbitals.
And now we're going to look at orbitals of be interim mixing with orbitals of a
right.
And which ones we might look at those two interacting for example,
mix those two with between a and B.
Or we could mix those two or those two or those two or those two or those two of
those students,
those two,
those are those do those over those two,
those two.
And it goes up infinitely.
So this is a problem.
Even if we understand how orbitals interact with one another,
we're going to have to narrow our focus if we want to deal with this.
Okay.
So let's look at,
so there are myriad possible pairwise mixings.
Now there's one that's going to be obviously important.
Suppose that molecule B has an odd number of electrons and therefore a singly
occupied molecular orbital.
And the same is true of molecule a.
Just suppose that happens,
right?
Then,
uh,
then when they come together and mix those two electrons will both go down in
energy.
So that's bound to be favorable,
substantially favorable,
and they'll get a new bond.
That's like two hydrogen atoms come together.
So if there are,
so Moe's on the two molecules and notice suppose be had of Somo but a didn't.
Right?
But you're not just talking about two molecules,
you're talking about two flasks.
If you mix it,
you had to have two bs that both had so most.
So a could be another B.
So if you have any SOMOS,
right,
that you can pair them be with B if he doesn't have any.
Right.
So if they exist,
if there's a somo then,
and that's true of many atoms or things called free radicals,
like the hydrogen atom,
the chlorine atom,
the methyl radical,
right,
then they're going to be very reactive.
Okay.
And for that very reason,
they're not very common.
You can't buy a bottle of methyl radicals because they will all have reacted
with one another.
The same for hydrogen atoms,
the same for chlorine atoms.
So that's an easy case to understand when you have SOMOS,
but it's very rare to encounter it unless you're talking about flames were lots
of things are atoms and free radicals as they're called.
We'll talk about that a lot more at the end of the semester.
Okay.
Now how about there too?
That could mix.
It's not bad energy match.
Right?
And suppose they have good overlap or do you care about that one?
Why Not Lucas?
Oh,
it exists.
It's an orbital.
There no electrons to have that energy.
It's a,
it's an available energy,
but nobody availed themselves of it so it doesn't contribute anything.
Right.
So that's,
there's nothing there.
So forget that one and you can forget a whole button.
You can free up most of them for this reason.
Right?
Of the infinite number.
Okay.
Now how about this pair?
Now they do,
they have let's suppose to have good overlap.
They're not bad energy match.
Right?
So two electrons will go down and two will go up.
Do you care
Stephen,
since those two?
Yeah.
So they more or less cancel.
Do they exactly cancel
[inaudible]
in which direction did they not canceled?
Corey
I love lower one is
even worse.
The lower one is bonding but bigger.
By bigger you mean greater than one over the square root of two kinds of things.
So,
so our adult,
pardon me,
less than one over the square root of two is smaller.
That's what you should have said.
Okay.
It's smaller so it doesn't go down as much as the upper one goes up.
So pretty much they cancel.
But to the extent they don't cancel,
it's repulsive.
It's heart bad to come together,
which means the molecules will bounce off,
right?
So when you have filled orbitals hitting one another,
the molecules repel one another.
Okay?
So,
uh,
that's weak net repulsion.
That's not going to explain a reaction.
Uh,
now how about here?
Now we're mixing a filled or,
but with a vacant orbital,
so two electrons go down.
So you don't have this canceling.
Is this going to be important?
This one,
Josh.
Oh,
the energy matches so bad that you don't get very much going down.
Not enough to make up for the fact that there,
if they'll come together,
they're going to be a lot of other orbitals molecular orbitals overlapping and
they're going to be repulsive.
The kinder we just looked at.
So this week attraction,
it's not going to be worth much.
Okay.
How about,
so it's negligible mixing because of bad energy match.
Now,
how about here?
Now that's not bad energy match.
I mean,
it's not great energy match,
but it's certainly better than any other pair of occupied with vacant.
Okay?
So that means though that pair,
we'll go down,
right?
And you'll get bonding if the energy matches good enough that the amount that he
go down is significant.
Okay?
So remember when we tried the same thing,
the other direction from the highest one on the right to the lowest one on the
left,
the energy match was not good.
So that didn't help.
But this one where it's high on the left and low on the right,
that one will help.
Okay?
So what it requires to have a reaction is that you have a high homo and
unusually high homo on one molecule and an unusually low Lumo on the other so
that you have good energy match,
or at least as good as you can get,
right?
Then you could get a reaction.
And it turns out that they're simple names for things that have unusually high
homos and things that have unusually low lumos.
And you know what those names are
something that has an unusually high homo is called a base and something that
has an unusually low Lumo is called
and acid,
right?
So that's a generalization of the idea of acid and base.
Most mixing of Mos affects neither the overall energy nor the overall electron
distribution for one or more of these reasons.
Okay.
First the electron occupancy can be for that is both were occupied,
which means to go up and to go down.
And the ones that go up and go up a little more.
So that's not a bond or zero and you don't care about the energy or the energy
matches poor.
So there's not much mixing all together or there's poor overlap.
So even if the energy match,
we're good,
you wouldn't get anything out of it.
But if you have high homo and low Lumo mixing,
then you get reactivity unusually high homo and unusually low Lumo.
And that's the secret we've been going for all semester.
So here's increasing generality in the concept of acid and base.
The idea of the names were introduced,
uh,
by,
lavoie ca in 1789 and we'll talk about that.
And from his point of view,
and acid was a base was an element of substance that could be oxidized and an
acid.
It was something that had been oxidized.
Like sulfur was a base oxidized sulfur.
Sulfuric acid was an acid.
Phosphorus was a base oxidized foster.
So as phosphoric acid,
carbon was a base.
Oxidized carbon was carbonic acid.
Okay.
Then in a hundred years later,
Arrhenius in Sweden,
uh,
said that an acid was something that was,
had the idea that there were ions,
things that were charged and that a thing that would give h plus was an acid and
a thing that would give ooh minus was a base.
That's the radius as theory.
And that was further generalized in 1923 by Runstead and Lowery.
Uh,
Runstead was a Dane and Lowery,
an Englishman who said that,
that an acid was not,
was an h plus donor.
That's the same as the radius.
But the base was something that it could accept h plus not only ooh minus,
but ammonia for example,
could accept,
uh,
could accept a base.
And Lewis then in the same year had the idea that an acid was something that
could accept an electron pair,
like Bh three and a base was something that could donate an electron pair like
ammonia.
Right?
And the other names for those acceptors and donors are electro file,
something that loves electrons,
will accept them at a nucleophile,
something that loves the nucleus is something that will give electrons to it.
But in the 1960s this was generalized finally to where it is now,
that that an unusually low vacant orbital is something that can accept
electrons,
electrons like to be in a low energy orbital.
So that is the ultimate definition of what an acid is.
And by the same token,
an unusually high homo has electrons that are eager to avail themselves of some
vacant orbital to lower their energy.
And that is a base.
Okay.
So as so often in science,
as the science matures,
you get more and more generality to the idea and homo and Lumo unusually high
Hobo,
unusually low Lumo are the,
uh,
the ultimate form of acid base.
And that's what we'll be talking about.
But they have to be unusual.
Why do they have to be unusually high and unusually low?
Otherwise you don't have good energy match to change the electron energies when
they come together.
Okay,
now here's what you should have asked.
Unusual compared to what,
okay,
so here is what we're organic chemists.
If we were some other kinds of chemists in some other universe dealing with
different elements,
we'd have different points of comparison.
But what we deal with is things that have a lot of carbon and hydrogen in them.
And by far,
our most common bonds are among,
between carbons are between carbon and hydrogen.
So it turns out that the valence orbitals of carbon,
the SP hybrid orbitals of carbon,
and that one s orbital of hydrogen are roughly the same in energy.
For our purposes,
we'll consider them to be the same.
Okay,
so you bring two of these together.
They overlap and you get sigma and Sigma Star,
and we've talked about that,
the bonding and the anti-bonding orbital.
So most of the occupied orbitals we're dealing with our cc sigma or c h sigma,
and most of the anti-bonding are orbitals are sigma star ch or sigma star Cc.
So those are our point of comparison.
Those are the plain vanilla electrons and holes.
Okay,
now let's look at other things and see whether they're unusual with respect to
this.
Now there will be several classes that they fall into,
right?
So those are the usual Lumo and the usual homo and or the CC analogs.
Now,
what could make things weird?
One thing can make things weird is that if you had valence,
shell atomic orbitals that didn't get mixed with anything.
So they're not sigma or Sigma Star bonding or antibiotic,
they're the original orbital in between these.
So that would make things unusual.
A second one would be a little bit in between these two when the,
if there's no overlap,
then you have unmixed orbitals.
If there's a lot of overlap,
you get bonds.
But there could be poor overlap,
in which case you don't go down as far with your bonding orbital or up as far
with your antibiotic overdose.
So a second case would be poor overlap.
A third case would be that the actual atomic energy that the atomic orbital
energy that you're using the Adam you're using is not like carbon and hydrogen.
So it starts at a completely different place from where the standard orbital
start before they make the molecular.
The bonding orbitals and forth could be if there's charge around,
because obviously if you have a negative charge,
it's not such a good place to put electrons.
That means the orbitals are high in energy.
If you have a net positive charge,
it's a good place to put electrons.
It's low in energy,
so charge can make it.
So we're going to show examples of these four contributors that will allow you
to identify when a molecule has an unusual orbital energy,
right?
Unusually High Homo,
unusually low Lumo,
and then you know that it'll be a functional group.
And you also know what the will react with because if you have an unusually high
high homo,
it'll react with an unusually low Lumo and vice versa.
Okay,
so first let's look at the first one.
Uh,
unmixed valence,
shell atomic,
orbitals.
So h plus our radius is acid,
right?
That's,
that's a vacant orbital,
right?
No Electron in it.
So that's obviously unusually low.
It's where this started the one s of hydrogen before it went up or down.
So if you had h plus,
it would be an unusually low vacant orbital.
How about Nh three,
right?
It has an unshared pair only on the nitrogen.
Now it likes being on nitrogen compared to carbon or hydrogen.
Why?
What makes it better to be on nitrogen?
Innovalon shell orbital than on the unshared pair than to be on high and
unshared pair on carbon or on hydrogen?
Angela,
there's more protons in the nucleus.
It's a lower energy orbital to start with,
right?
So,
but that it didn't mix with anything.
They're Nh bonds in ammonia,
right?
And they've mixed and went way down in energy and a vacant orbital went up in
energy.
But the unshared pair didn't mix with anything,
so it still has that original energy.
So it's unusually high compared to what?
Compared to wild
CHC or cc sigma.
That's our point of comparison.
Okay.
Or the,
the flip side of that is BH three which has a vacant orbital.
It's high to start with compared with a hydrogen or a carbon because Boron
doesn't have very big nuclear charge.
Right.
And it's,
and it's,
and it's nucleus is screened,
right?
So it's an unusually hot,
it's unusually high for an atom,
but it's still atomic.
It didn't mix with anything and go up further.
Right.
So it's unusually low for a vacant orbital.
So be h three is a low,
unusually low Lumo.
So is it an acid or a base
which
you've read through lecture?
You don't get the vote.
It's like h plus,
right?
An unusually low Lumo so it's an acid.
How about Nh?
Three.
So base,
unusually high homo.
Okay.
How about water?
Right.
It is unshared.
Pairs of electrons.
You know,
Lucas,
can we just say that they both had these properties because they
charge,
we use nitrogen.
That nitrogen has heightened,
which has loaded with nitrogen,
is hot and loans that are charged from pair to carpet.
Yeah,
and VHR is even lower
energies food or is it just because of the [inaudible]?
But remember you have to bear in mind which row of the periodic table you're in,
right?
HM,
true.
It only has one proton,
but you're talking a one s orbital low and energy for carbon,
nitrogen,
oxygen,
Boron.
You're talking two S,
right?
So that,
so that you're changing the game.
No,
no.
Not between Bh three days.
H three is unusually high energy for an occupied or orbital.
Bh Three is unusually low,
although it's high compared to nitrogen.
It's low for a vacant orbital.
It's an unusually low Lumo nitrogen,
unusually high homo.
Now,
oxygen is lower than nitrogen,
so water is a base,
but it's not as good as not as good as base as ammonia because its electrons
aren't as high because it has a bigger nuclear charge and the same end,
it's in the first complete row of the periodic table.
Okay,
Ooh.
Minus is even higher.
It's a stronger base than water.
Why?
Why are its electrons higher in energy then water,
not less protons,
right?
It's got,
it's got a net negative large,
which makes all the electrons high in energy,
and specifically the pair.
We care about the highest one unusually I,
because it's got a negative charge website.
Press the wrong button there.
Okay.
Ch three minus is even more of a base because carbon doesn't have as many as
big.
A nuclear charge is oxygen.
So when it has a negative charge,
it's a really high homo.
Okay.
I gotta quit there.
We'll go on to two,
three,
and four next time.